okay so yeah I'm currently a postdoc
here at Stanford I'm also a technology
you fellow at the Electronic Frontier
Foundation so I'll be talking some about
my academic research and also about some
of the work I've done at EF F to promote
secure messaging tools to try to help
people understand different secure
messaging tools and what properties they
provide so the context of all this
really in the last couple years we have
some good evidence from I mean there's
there's tons of anecdotal evidence but
there's also hard evidence from talking
to people that people are much more
concerned about surveillance than they
used to be yeah but you know this shows
that both in surveys and also from the
ef-s perspective after the Snowden
revelations the F F got tons and tons of
queries from all sorts of different
organizations they said what can we do
to to protect our communications from
from surveillance what can we tell the
dissidents that we work with what can we
tell the journalists that we work with
about how they can protect their
communications so this has been a really
really big topic you know I think
there's some evidence that people don't
don't totally understand what the real
threats are if you look at data from
this same survey people are much less
worried about using a landline phone
than they are about sending email using
chatter I am which is what I'll be
mostly talking about today is sort of
chat or I am or messaging tools so you
know people don't exactly understand
what's going on because they still think
that using a using a landline is secure
here it's really not I mean this is
probably the least secure of all the
communication channels here I would say
you know using a plain old telephone
system is basically the the worst you
can do there's no encryption there's
there's no real possibility for
end-to-end encryption so if you're
worried about kind of government
surveillance this is you know not it's
not a great place to be so I'll come
back to this seem later that users don't
exactly understand what their
afraid of or what security properties
different channels have but for now I
just wanted to say that people are
definitely more worried about
surveillance than they they have been so
the the high level bit that came out of
the Snowden docks that was positive is
that there was no evidence really
anywhere in the docks besides a couple
of things kind of circumstantially it
people have patched in there wasn't much
evidence that you know the main
cryptographic protocols we have are
actually broken
um in a few places there was actually
evidence that NSA was frustrated when
people were using PGP because they
didn't actually know how to how to
decrypt and read the the messages so
when people use cryptography from
everything we know it still works it
doesn't appear you know even that NSA
has a magic way to break the good
cryptography that we have when it's
actually used so the problem of course
is that it's famously really hard to
actually use cryptography so how many
people have used PGP ok so most people
so Henry is a holdout there yeah so I'll
just show you a couple clips from this
this video which I think if you've never
seen this video I think really drives
the point home really well but this
video was actually made by Edward
Snowden and given to Glenn Greenwald the
journalist that he was working with and
Glenn Greenwald said you know at the
beginning of his conversations the
Snowden he really didn't know anything
about encryption or security so we had
to to get up to speed to to to
rendezvous with Snowden and kind of
services liaison to the public so you'll
notice this video is going to be 12
minutes long so you know right off the
bat if it takes 12 minutes to explain to
the public how to use a piece of
technology at that time budget is kind
of way too long
it yeah so you can see so so it's kind
of a fun video
doesn't actually use the voice masking
technology here which is why it's hard
to recognize his voice that was by
design
so anyway spend some time kind of
talking about the threat model and then
he starts walking through how to
actually use PGP software on Windows and
it's really a mess I mean you can kind
of look along the bottom of the screen
here you know at the beginning of the
window is just at the beginning of this
video it's just the web browser that's
open and it's kind of slowly builds up
by the end of the video he gets you know
almost his entire a system tray here
full of applications that he's running
so there's like a lot of stuff going on
at this point right here you know that
he's now creating keys kind of five
minutes into it and there's one point
see if I can jump to it where he's
actually you know copying keys he's
using notepad he's copying and pasting
the key and ASCII just import it from
the tool that created it to the email
client that's gonna actually use it
there's parts in this video where he
says oh like you know you have to hit
that checkbox or else the whole thing is
insecure there's kind of gems throughout
but it's a it's a pretty clear sign that
you know this PGP is over 20 years old
now I guess almost 25 years old and it's
never really grown into a technology
that people were comfortable with using
so we have a lot of evidence for that
claim beyond just one video the video is
more fun there are also a lot of
academic studies in in the lab they
brought users in and given them tasks to
say you know can you install PGP
software can you communicate with these
people a lot of people just don't do it
at all it just blocks their
communication a lot of people will in
those experiments that one evitable send
things out in plain text they'll do
things like you know encrypt to their
own public key and then sent to somebody
else so you know we have pretty hard
numbers that this this doesn't work so
well in practice and if you need any
more convincing this was
maybe the most fun anecdote from my time
at EF F I was working with Phil
Zimmerman on a project so Phil Zimmerman
was the original developer who created
PGP so you know I made sure the first
time I emailed him that I PDP encrypted
the message and he just responded in
plain text sorry I don't do PGP anymore
so just send this back in plain text and
I asked when I got this I said you have
to let me use this and talks and tweet
about it because this is so perfect that
even the person who the person who made
this software found it too unusable to
actually use so that's kind of this
state that we've been in for a while
where cryptographers have historically
not devoted too many resources to this
problem there's a by now pretty famous
paper that was written last year called
the moral character of cryptographic
work arguing that you know the
cryptographers sort of owe more to
society than this and to sort of ignore
and marginalize this work on making
things actually easy to use to be honest
I'm not sure this paper has really swung
more researchers to get into this
problem
I think it's gaining a little bit of
traction but you know it's been a it's
been a real problem to get
cryptographers especially in the
academic setting to stop sort of or
maybe not spend all their time chasing
the next big algorithmic or theoretical
breakthrough and try to make the things
that we've had forever actually easy and
and secure for people to use in practice
okay so you know I basically told you
that PGP is mostly dead I think very few
people are really even trying to revive
it at this point I mean it's still very
much alive and that a lot of people have
used it but I think we have-we have
pretty clear evidence that it's sort of
not the the mass-market solution that
people hoped it would be messages they
sent out encrypted as opposed to clear
text using in my personal communications
anybody who sent more than ten yeah yeah
it's it's a good question I mean I guess
there are some I don't know about people
there are some email addresses that are
always encrypted but in terms of like an
actual human being I don't know I think
most people will have an unencrypted
email address for sort of you know
signing up for accounts and maybe
emailing friends small stuff so yeah I
mean I would certainly agree with your
your statement there that most people
don't encrypt very much of their email
over PGP even if they use PGP okay so
the scene for PGP is kind of grim but at
the same time in the last few years
we've had a somewhat quiet but a
revolution and how much and and
encryption is actually happening and all
the action is happening on chat
applications or messaging applications
basically software that you download on
your phone and that gives you kind of an
ephemeral chat experience and the two
biggest ones iMessage from Apple and
whatsapp so you know each of these apps
has a user base that's in the hundreds
of millions to billions of users and
everything is now end and encrypted all
the time so you know in in human history
these are by far the majority of
encrypted communications that have ever
happened have been over whatsapp and
iMessage just the amount of encrypted
traffic that's gone through those two
systems is vastly more than the amount
that ever went through PGP and its
entire lifetime so I'm is everything
okay okay so yes so in a sense that's
that's really exciting and I think the
most interesting thing is that most
users who use whatsapp actually don't
even know that it's encrypted
and the same thing is true for iMessage
so it's kind of completely transparent
to the users that are using the app but
everything is encrypted now in fact
until about a a year ago whatsapp wasn't
encrypted so this is some
that they added after the fact and they
were able to add in and an encryption
which we saw for email is sort of this
this crippling ly difficult thing to use
they were able to do it without even
changing the user experience and there
are a whole lot of other apps that have
launched that offer some level of end
and encryption including I know it's
really confusing because almost every
one of these apps has some version of
the same logo which is a chat bubble
with some kind of lock on it but you
know this is Facebook messenger which
also has hundreds of millions of users
and this is Google's new messenger which
is supposed to replace Google Hangouts
so Facebook and Google have sort of
gotten on board the end-to-end
encryption train well that's important
to note there's a big difference in that
Facebook and Google users have to
actually explicitly turn on the end end
encryption so they have to choose to
have what's called a secret chat or is
with whatsapp and iMessage
everything's ending encrypted by default
you don't have a choice to fall back to
in secure mode so it's interesting that
they've different there so yeah so
signal just happens to be right here so
I'm sure a lot of you have heard of
signal hopefully we have a lot of signal
users signal it has you know the order
of magnitude that we're talking is about
one or two million users so it's at
least two maybe three orders of
magnitude smaller and I think a good way
to think about signal is it's kind of
like a Formula One car in a way it's
kind of pioneering the new technology
and in fact signals encryption protocol
moved from signal to whatsapp so signal
is sort of more cutting-edge they're
adding more more features and sort of
experimenting on security but it's
always going to be kind of a smaller
user base because it's a security
focused thing it doesn't have as many as
many of the features that users like for
fun kind of emojis and sharing
animations and things like that
so that's that's how I do its role just
something you might be invested
we're powers back oh so I guess the rest
of this talk will be sort of talking
about that a little bit from a tech
perspective from a from a from a legal
perspective you know I I'm not a lawyer
so that's a pretty complicated question
I think even the lawyers id-ff have been
thinking about fur for a while and it's
really not not clear I mean obviously we
you know 3ff we were involved in a big
fight over iMessage that wasn't it
wasn't that you're sorry about Apple it
wasn't about iMessage specifically it
was about encrypted devices but I think
the shortest answer is were probably
headed for a big decisive court case
sometime in the next five years or so
and then we'll have a more of a clear
answer okay so it's a little bit fuzzy
this is not really a technical
definition but you know people ask why
is there so much more encryption
happening on these messaging apps than
on email there are some different
characteristics here that have made this
possible for one you know email is this
kind of open federated system that PGP
tried to build on top of but that made
it very hard it's been hard to sort of
upgrade PGP so compatibility was always
a big problem whereas all of these chat
apps are walled gardens so they're all
yeah they're all walled gardens so they
all have or one official application so
you have to use sort of the official
software and there's one server
unlike email which is open and you can
email anybody else and then you know
from the technical standpoint at the
bottom here you know two differences
that make encryption easier the user
experience that people expect from a
messaging app is that it's an ephemeral
conversation so if you lose your old
messages people expect that to happen
whereas email people expect to stay
around forever they expect that any
device anywhere they go they can
download all their old previous emails
traditionally we thought of email as
being you know purely asynchronous that
you can always send anybody a email and
it stays on their server and their
mailbox until they download it
whereas a lot of messaging apps were
synchronous of both people would be
online they could do a key exchange and
that makes security a lot simpler this
distinction is breaking down a little
bit
a lot of the messaging apps are actually
moving to an asynchronous model now for
a variety of reasons but at least
initially that was something that we
thought was different between these two
but I I mean I think that the the
biggest change really is the fact that
these apps are walled gardens so it's
much easier to to roll out some
proprietary encryption protocol and sort
of update it without asking the users to
change what they're doing and without
worrying about backwards compatibility
since there's basically one one set of
client software you can upgrade
everybody at once to use new encryption
tools so why are these apps doing it
there's a couple of different reasons I
mean the we'd like to think that the
only reason that people encrypt is to do
right by their users and to give them a
secure experience and to maintain users
privacy turns out from talking to these
companies through my role at the FF I
found there's two other big reasons why
they're interested in rolling out
encryption one is to reduce their
liabilities so if you don't store a
bunch of your users messages then you
can't be hacked you can't be liable for
it and the other one which is really
interesting is that if you don't have to
serve requests to law enforcement when
they come and ask for user data that's
just a whole process that you can
eliminate from your business which is
really nice and my favorite story to
that effect is a messaging app called
kik which doesn't actually make any
information public about whether or not
they're doing encryption they don't
promote themselves as a secure tool they
don't commit to the fact that they're
doing encryption but if you go to their
page that they've set up for law
enforcement then they say oh we can't
actually give you any data because it's
all encrypted so seemingly their only
motivation to employ some sort of
encryption was just so that they didn't
have to deal with law enforcement
requests for data on the other side you
know that
the sort of hang-ups that have kept you
know Facebook and Google the reasons why
they didn't turn on encryption by
default for everybody and they made it
kind of this optional mode that very few
people use Google specifically in the
last few months when they launched a low
they said they were really excited about
their smart assistant feature so while
you're chatting the way the app is
intended to work is that if you're
chatting about going to dinner the app
will pop up suggestions of restaurants
and things like that so the entire time
you're communicating your data is sort
of being sent to Google servers to
provide these these assistance services
which get turned off if you go
end-to-end and they they said that there
for most of their users the users care
more about having this rich experience
and they do about encryption so that was
the the choice that they made a couple
other reasons being able to deal with
spam so doing content based spam
filtering what comes a lot harder if
everything's encrypted you know fairly
straightforward also sort of abusive
users that people are sending abusive
messages things like that much much
harder to police these these encrypted
apps and just providing sort of the
experience people want where they can
have all of their past communications
stored on the server and they can you
know they can search they can sort of
sync with any new device all of those
things become vastly harder once you
encrypt everything yeah gets bright so
it's a little more complicated now in
signal because they have you can sync on
multiple devices but by default no so
like if the simplest case if you just
have one one device and you install
signal and then you drop that device in
in the lake then your messages are gone
that's actually a you know that is a big
issue with with iMessage so you know
there's a big caveat to the fact that I
message is encrypted which is that by
default all of your I messages do
backed up in plain text to the Apple
server their encrypted with your Apple
account ID so they're they're basically
password encrypted which is kind of weak
but a lot of the how-to guides on how to
use iMessage securely make a specific
point that you should disable backups it
is kind of funny because they've
encrypted everything but then they back
the plaintext up but you can you can
turn it off if you want to yeah the
channel itself the end points are still
of course yeah so that's that's all
crypto is ever gonna get you as sort of
the data is only accessible at the
endpoints clear absolutely the analyst
breaking through a server may be more
difficult than doing it to a endpoint
way out of the tree but you know that
could be true but at least the hope is
that breaking into endpoints doesn't
scale as well so if you want to do mass
surveillance much much easier to do at
the server than to try to compromise
every endpoint so that's that's the help
but obviously that's a caveat to
everything is that if you if users can't
have a secure endpoint if they don't
have the you know legitimate software to
do the encryption then you know
nothing's gonna work out okay so the the
main technical weak point which all
spend some time talking about is how
users actually get the right key to do
encryption so the way all of these apps
work right now they have a centralized
key server so when Alice signs up she
uploads her public key to the key server
when Bob wants to send Alice a message
she just asked the key server for
Alice's key and obviously if the key
server is malicious the key server can
tell Bob that Alice's key is something
else at which point that the server can
man-in-the-middle the traffic you know
to their heart's content and the one of
the difficult things here is that for
all these apps again the key server also
sees all of the traffic because all of
communication gets funneled through
central servers there's no you know
peer-to-peer communication happening
here so if they're in a very very good
position to man them at all all the
traffic if they want to so the security
of the whole system relies on Alice and
Bob being able to somehow communicate
not mediated by the key server to ask if
Bob has the right key to be encrypting
to Alice so solving this problem is the
the main security challenge that we have
to make these apps actually secure so if
you've used signal or whatsapp or lots
of other apps that have some version of
this the the classic answer we've had is
that you do key verification so you look
at a fingerprint of your key you read it
out you compare maybe you do this in
person
maybe you trust some other channel but
that's the idea
I mean signal also supports a qr-code
way to do this if you're in person but
pretty pretty painful to actually do
this how many people have have actually
verified a key and signal or another
tool by hand yeah so a couple folks and
yeah so pretty painful there have been
some research efforts to try to make
this more usable or at least more fun by
showing the the key in a more
interesting way there's a library for
expressing these keys as random art
there's this is one that does robot so
those two robots represent different
keys
there's one that does it with unicorns
this thing on the bottom here turns your
key into a random poem for the most part
this hasn't really been backed up by a
good research saying that this is
actually users get this right more often
you know it's definitely more fun
although most of the apps have kind of
shied away from this because it causes
users to think that the app is not as
serious even though you're representing
maybe the same amount of mint
repiy in just a different way if it's a
poem or if it's a bunch of hex users
actually get a much better feeling
reading hex than they do reading a poem
because I guess I don't know I was
thinking that maybe instead of having a
poem with sort of flowery texts like
this they need to make it seem like it's
some top-secret spy movie thing what
yeah so I think you know this is sort of
a very marginal change to the experience
that's probably not going to solve the
the fact that most users don't want to
do it haha I must have seen where I was
going so some apps do do this if you
have the voice channel available you can
read some again some fingerprint of the
key if you're online you can actually
you don't have to read a long
fingerprint you can do a short
authentication string so you really only
need to have the person read about
thirty bits so that seems great the user
experience is much better users like it
much more it's very fast the problem is
that is actually not secure so there's a
really cool paper at CCS a few years ago
where they used voice morphing software
so if you have a very short sample of
Alice's voice you can quickly synthesize
Alice saying whatever you want and over
the kind of fidelity of voice channel
that you get in these Apps users fall
for it every time
what and yeah you can think I was having
a cold so so you're not doing you're not
it's there's no machine voice
recognition here the idea is that Alice
is reading this short string to Bob and
then Bob says oh that really sounds like
Alice so therefore there's no man in the
middle here so the recognition is being
done by a human but yeah well I think
that's that's the real one of the one of
the real reasons that users fall for it
so much is that you're not expecting
your
the expected result is that you're
talking to the person that you think you
are and it's your brain will basically
map what you hear to their voice even if
it's awful a little bit so I mean they I
think they had some samples posted where
you could hear and if you if you're
really listening critically you can sort
of tell that it's not quite right but in
real time when you're not primed to
expect that something's happening your
your brain just completely fills it in
and people don't notice at all so you
could argue that this isn't the easiest
attack to pull off you know you you if
you wanted to do this on a massive scale
you need to invest in a lot of resources
to be doing voice morphing in real time
for all these different users all over
the place but essentially to a large
adversary that we'd be worried about a
state-level adversary that was doing
mass surveillance the voice approach
doesn't doesn't really work there's been
a couple of other attempts to kind of
reimagine this I'll just show a few
seconds of this video the the innovation
here is that if you're doing this in
person exchange rather than having
people actually verify oh yeah see make
it fullscreen this thing rather than
having people actually verify you do
this line in a synchronous exchange and
then swinging keys a couple though the
parties check and see if there are there
things match and then pick the 100
provide an echo compatibility an
authentication against men in the middle
attacks and then that's kind of enough
to be the exchange to import your
friends your keys so the interesting
thing about that protocol that I really
like is that it the failure mode is not
just that users click OK and then
everything proceeds
you're not actually allowed to start
talking unless the two parties both pick
the same fingerprint that was shown on
both screens so if they use
aren't paying attention then other thing
will fail because they won't pick the
same same thing but unfortunately I mean
you have to actually this is still I
mean it took them a three minute video
to explain how to use it so better than
12 minutes but it's still a little bit
complicated and you have to actually
meet the person in person to use this
protocol one of their approach that has
seen some excitement over the last
couple years is called key base does
anybody have a key base profile okay so
we have a couple of key base fans so the
idea behind key base is that you you
verify or at least you gain some
confidence that the key you have is
correct by linking it to some different
different profiles that this person has
on the web and there's actually a
cryptographic pairing that happens here
um so you you get this big document
which is basically a proof that this
specific key with this fingerprint here
is owned by the same entity that owns
all of these social media profiles and
you pair it securely by posting in these
different locations so to verify that
this is really Maxis Witter account max
is going to post this string which is
basically a signature under this key
sort of asserting that this key and this
Twitter profile are linked and then for
different kinds of social media sites
there's different places where you shove
this information but the idea is that
you're proving that the same person
really owns all these different things
and then the hope is that users can look
at this and say you know I obviously
like max crone the human being is a
little bit of a nebulous concept
technically but you can prove that it's
somebody who owns all of these and if
you know max and know that those are all
him then you might have pretty high
confidence that this is the right key
for the person that you want to talk to
but again this is kind of a lot of work
to set up I think it's maybe a little
bit more of a boutique solution than
something that everybody in the world is
going to do
so these are all different methods that
you can try to do the the key
verification out-of-band they all have
the same weak point which is that every
time your key changes you have to redo
the process so key changes are pretty
painful in signal every time somebody
that you talk to changes their key you
get this warning message that says you
know Bob's key is something different
now do you still want to talk to Bob do
you want to cancel maybe you need to
Rivera fie key Bay's from giving out of
their supposed to go Max's Twitter
accounts and check with that fingerprint
matches um so they they like the there's
software that will do it automatically
for you yeah like it will fetch the the
right tweet and fetch all of this so you
get kind of this electronic dossier
thing that you know asserts all of these
pairings and then there's client
software that will actually sort of
follow all the links and check all the
signatures and assert that everything is
actually the job so the goal is that for
the user you just get this list here and
then you have to make the decision if
these user names are really the person
you want to talk to yeah I haven't seen
any I don't have any evidence that it
won't be you know this is key base is
still a pretty new thing so I haven't
seen any any research on a if people can
use it and B if people are able to make
the right decision here I mean I think
to me one one tough part of this is that
for a lot of users they don't really
have very recognizable handles I mean
Twitter is one of the few platforms
where people tend to know what what
someone's Twitter handle is independent
from their name or their email address a
lot of the things like Facebook Facebook
doesn't give most users a handle that
they really recognize you know to find
users on Facebook you search and a
search page kind of disambiguates so
so I think it would be a great research
project to see how well users do with
this okay so like I was saying every
time you change keys it's painful you
get this message you know it's a pretty
scary message for users
I think engineers sort of tend to treat
this as a detail to not worry too much
about because how often do users really
change keys it turns out that users
change keys at a pretty high rate so
this is I guess from back in the text
secure days that I got this data but
basically about 1% of the users of
signal change their keys every day so
that's kind of the daily turnover in the
key directory at signal which is it's
pretty huge most people when they first
see that say like why is it possibly so
big it turns out the the market research
on phones the half-life of a phone when
somebody buys a mobile phone the
half-life is like seven to eight months
I'm so really really short people just
break phones a lot and they lose them
and a lot of people like to upgrade
devices so every time that happens users
usually change keys because they usually
don't transfer the old keys to the new
new phone also users just uninstall the
app and reinstall it for kind of strange
reasons offer a method to either
transfer directly from one instance to
the other or back up yeah the key yeah
it's a good question I'm not sure like
exactly which apps do and don't offer
backup I know signal does I know that I
message and whatsapp certainly do but
you're sort of in a tough place because
if you make the backups automatic it's a
security problem because then you're
uploading everybody's private key to
some server somewhere and if it's a
manual thing where you have to take the
old device in the new device in Parratt
a lot of people won't have the old
device because it will be at the bottom
of a lake and even if they have the old
device they a lot of people just aren't
going to do it
so the assumption is basically users
change device and they get a new key
okay so you know we've been talking
about manually verifying keys I'd
propose that there's sort of this Iron
Triangle of things you'd like with your
key distribution system three properties
that are hard to have at the same time
you'd like it to be secure you'd like it
to be decentralized so we're not
trusting some central entity to behave
itself and we'd like it to be easy to
use so manual verification not easy to
use but secure and decentralized if you
don't care too much about security you
can just do trust on first use which
means whatever key you first hear
somebody tell you you just kind of trust
forever that obviously is not very
secure because if you talk to the wrong
person first then you're sort of
insecure forever the approach that
essentially all of these tools use in
practice is they just use a trusted key
server which is easy you know secure
modulo the trust you have in the key
server but you know the trust and the
key server is a big thing yeah so yes
I'll just say that there's a couple of
different reasons that having a trusted
authority to give out keys wins out in
practice you can deal with you can deal
with scale much better you can deal with
account recovery because they can just
sort of mandate that you have a new key
in particularly you can do any kind of
out-of-band recovery that you want so
the user experience if you're an
iMessage user if you lose your device
you can show up at the Apple Store you
know down on university or wherever
they'll actually check your ID or
they'll verify you know they'll do
social security number or whatever kind
of hokey security thing that they do but
and they'll actually verify in person
that you're still the same person even
if you've sort of lost all of your
devices and then they'll just you know
update on the server that your new
public key is you know whatever you want
it to be so you know it's very hard to
do this kind of
out-of-band recovery if you don't have a
trusted central server some other
properties they think are you know
people overlook there have been a lot of
attempts to do this using block chains
with systems like namecoin if anybody
has seen namecoin those systems usually
fall apart because there's no way to
deal with name squatting or people
taking all of the good and interesting
names and if you have a trusted server
they can sort of do policing and you
know services like Twitter do this all
the time where they try to make sure
that names really correspond to people
and if someone is taking a name
maliciously twitter will take it back
from you okay so that's just sort of the
quick case for why I don't think this
model is going away I think you know the
the main success we've seen is with apps
that just have a central key server so
the technical question that I've been
really interested in that I've done some
research on is how can we ensure that
this authority behaves correctly so it's
a little bit of a weaker goal a lot of
the time and a lot of the time in
cryptography the goal is to remove third
parties entirely and replace them with
some cryptographic protocol the goal
here is to leave the third party in
place but use a little bit of crypto to
try to verify that the third party is
actually behaving correctly so this was
the inspiration for a project called
conics that I worked on and what conics
does is we say we want to leave the key
server in place but we want to sort of
guarantee that it behaves consistently
and when I say consistently the one
property that we really want is that
whatever the key server tells Bob the
key server also has to tell Alice so Bob
can ask the key server what's Alice's
public key the key server can say
whatever it wants but whatever it says
it has to also say the same thing to
Alice if she asks right so the server
can lie can be malicious but if it lies
it has to tell the same lie to everybody
I can't equivocate two different parties
okay so why is that property actually
useful now Bob knows that the server
might be lying but Bob doesn't have to
worry about it
Bob can say if the server is lying Alice
will see the same lie and then Alice can
deal with the problem she's better
positioned to know what the server
should be telling the world her public
key is than I am so I'm just gonna take
whatever the server says as the truth
and if it's wrong leave it to Alice to
figure out the problem so now your
client software only has to warn the
users that something's going wrong if
the server says something unexpected
about their own key so if you know if
Bob's key changes your you know if your
Alice your client your software never
has to warn you it never has to say
Bob's key isn't what it used to be the
only time it ever has to warn you is if
your key is something that you weren't
expecting it to be so the one warning
message that you would get in a system
like this would you know this is a mock
up this isn't you know this isn't the
well-tested UI but you'd get some
warning that would say the server has
published some key that wasn't what I
was expecting maybe reinstall the app or
did something funny if not then you know
there might be a problem with this
server the other great thing about this
besides the warning being simpler is
that you just generate a lot fewer
warnings so kind of in the the old way
of looking at it without consistency if
somebody changes their key you have to
warn everybody else in the world that
they talk to so if they have you know n
friends all end of those friends will
get a warning saying Bob's key just
changed but with consistency you only
generate one warning four key change
because the only person who gets warned
just the person had just changed their
key so that's the whole goal of this
project is to build a key server that we
have some hopefully high confidence is
behaving consistently plus a lot of
engineering constraints so we sort of
wanted this to scale we wanted this to
work with the way key servers were
right now there's privacy constraints so
I'll get into these constraints and this
this work is sort of positioned in a lot
of work that's happened in the last
three to four years on this idea of
transparency which is sort of using
servers that publish authenticated data
structures that people can verify to see
if the server is actually behaving
correctly so the most successful project
in this space sort of with this
philosophy is called certificate
transparency in some ways that's similar
so you have this certificate
transparency server that just maintains
a log of all the certificates in the
world sort of as long as you can audit
that they're behaving consistently
you'll at least see attacks if they
happen I'm such as to say you know
conics is very much kind of inspired by
this this whole line of work
so the actual data structure and context
it uses what's called a prefix tree it's
an authenticated data structure and
periodically the database changes every
time it changes the server you know
publishes a signature on the root of
this data structure and clients are
gonna track these okay so let's take a
look at what what this actually is so
this is the authenticated data structure
so this is the the prefix tree this
represents a mapping from users to keys
the server signs this route so that's a
commitment to the key of every user in
the system and then this signed root is
what users actually track so this epic
length you might think this might be
something like every minute or every 10
minutes the server publishes a new one
of these which commits to the entire
state of the database you can see sort
of over time this will change because
users will come and go users will change
keys etc so the fact that each sign root
includes the previous signed root so
that we're building a chain this means
that if the server ever equivocates
so if it ever tell
to different people you know if it ever
gives them two different versions of the
data structure it's going to have to
maintain this equivocation forever so as
long as the hash function is collision
resistant any equivocation the server
makes it's going to sort of have to
maintain forever so the server can't
equivocate but if it does it's sort of
stuck without equivocation and then you
have clients just audit for this so if
the if the server has published a
different set of routes to Alice and it
did to Bob their clients can check and
this is totally automatic so this is not
an out-of-band check that Alice and Bob
have to actually think about their their
software will just do this automatically
but they'll share the most recent route
that they've seen and if it's different
they'll know they have evidence that the
server's cheating and there's some other
ways to do this too it doesn't
necessarily have to be client stalking
you can also publish this series of sine
routes to some external log that's you
know hard too hard to modify like the
Bitcoin ledger and then your client can
check there to kind of for extra safety
to make sure that these sine routes that
this server gave you are also published
in this third-party log and the
assumption here so all these clients are
sort of auditing all the time and if the
server ever misbehaves if the server
have equivocates this is a really big
deal and we want the clients to be able
to whistleblow
that means they sort of publicize this
evidence to say you know this server
should no longer be trusted because it's
behaving and consistently technically
though this introduce is a couple of
interesting questions you know if you
have some app and it's only a way of
communicating with the world is through
this key server then it doesn't really
have a means of whistleblowing so it's
important that your your server can't be
essentially your gateway to the entire
Internet you have to have some way to
communicate with the wider world that
doesn't go through this central server
so you know if you were trying to use
this at the ISP level and the security
argument would fall apart a little bit
because that server could then you know
maybe reasonably prevent you from
whistleblowing if it misbehaved okay so
if the auditing process works and we can
trust that the server is not
equivocating everybody has a consistent
view then clients just have to monitor
their own binding their own entry in the
database to make sure that it's actually
correct so if the so you know
essentially at for every version of the
database you'll get this reduced proof
that just sort of shows what your entry
is in the database and if that's wrong
if that's some key that the server put
in the database maliciously for you then
your software will pop up that warning I
was talking about saying you know the
server has published some key for you
that wasn't expected now we have to deal
with the problem so we tried to engineer
this down you know as much as we could
I'll just sort of give you the the high
level figure we sort of simulated this
for you know if the entire population of
the planet was using this system you can
you can do it in the overhead is fairly
modest you're adding sort of you know
tens of tens of kilobytes per day that
you'd have to download to check that the
server is actually behaving consistently
so we were for from a research
standpoint we were you know pretty happy
with this we said yeah you download like
an extra seven kilobytes a day something
like that maybe even less that seems
like nothing I've actually been
surprised how many app developers I've
talked to they said like we have users
who downloading an extra five kilobytes
a day will be like a real problem for it
seems kind of crazy to me because you
know I download all these apps that that
download megabytes worth of advertising
without even asking me about it but I
guess you know if I learn one thing
talking to people who develop chat apps
they're very very paranoid about
bandwidth that's like the main thing
they worry about performance wise is
minimized
how much bandwidth the app uses yeah so
I'll talk about that in a second so I
wanted to talk about the privacy
concerns briefly so the main privacy
concern is that this authenticated data
structure if you do it naively it will
leak out the list of users who are using
the system so it doesn't sort of leak it
directly but there are there are attacks
where you can sort of add users and you
can do a binary search and you can
figure out whether or not certain users
exist in this tree I mean you can see
how you know these two versions of the
tree Alice will learn that she has a
neighbor here because you know Alice's
inclusion proof in this tree will be one
extra hop longer so she'll sort of know
some user you know if if this was the
state of the system and it changes to
this state Alice will know some user
that has a name that's close to me it
was just added so information is
basically being leaked here so why would
you care about that well if you think
like what if it's an email system most
email servers don't publish the entire
list of users at their system right
because people are worried about spam
maybe less so online today actually I
talked to the Gmail team about this back
when I was working at Google and this
was sort of a still a glimmer of an idea
and they were pretty confident with how
much good work they've done on spam I
said you know we think we've sort of won
the war on spam at gmail and most users
don't complain about spam anymore and I
said that's great so if we did this key
transparency system and as a result we
published the list of every Gmail
address would that be okay and then they
sort of backed off and they said well
spam is a really hard problem you know
you're you're asking a lot of us here so
no but I think that's fair that we don't
want to reveal the list of all usernames
in the system so kind of classic trick
we just added layer of indirection
cryptographic layer of indirection so
instead of actually
inserting usernames into the system we
run the usernames through what's called
a verifiable random function this is a
cryptographic function kind of takes any
input it spits out some output and it
also produces a proof that this
input/output pair is correct and it has
the property that you can't actually
compute it unless you have what works
out to be a private key so you know
given this it's fairly straightforward
to solve the privacy problem it turned
out there was some engineering problems
attached with this when we looked around
we sort of realized that the vrf the
concept had been around for a while and
the crypto literature but nobody was
actually doing it in practice so there's
a couple options here that didn't work
for various reasons they were either too
slow or used crypto libraries that
people didn't want to download so with
some help from Henry we cooked up a new
thing and this is actually this is
actually deployed in signal now which is
kind of cool we realized after this was
pushed for the first time that this
might be the first time people were
using this crypto construction I think
it took about 15 years from the time it
first appeared in a crypto paper to the
time when someone was actually using it
which you know if you look at the whole
crypto literature 15 years is like a
reasonably reasonably fast turnaround
actually so we fixed the privacy problem
instead of actually storing a mapping
from usernames to keys we store mapping
from these indices that are the outputs
of from the the random function and then
to actually check a binding you sort of
get that some opaque index X maps to a
key along with a proof that you know the
name Alice is what maps to X and then if
you don't have this proof it doesn't you
know you don't learn anything
interesting if you know that X is in the
database okay so that's the
Connex project so the you know the paper
I guess we wrote two years ago it's now
kind of an open source projects tour the
tour the tour foundation has released a
messaging app called tor messenger they
haven't actually released their
implementation of conics yet but they've
been working on it
google has they've kind of adapted it
and made some changes but they're also
doing a key transparency approach I
think it's exciting and to see that sort
of people who are developing chat apps
you know they want to prove that they're
actually reputable okay so there is a
and asked about sort of the performance
trade-off how much work is it to do if
someone's been offline for a while so
that is definitely the trade-off you
know there's a trade-off of how often
you publish new versions of the tree if
you wait a long time between publishing
then it takes a long time for changes to
happen people have to wait to actually
use their new key but if you make it too
short you know if you try to publish
them every second and you go offline for
a month and you'll have millions of
these things that you have to to go back
in time and check so there's sort of two
performant acts that you can try one is
to have this concept of promises where
you get a promise from the server that
something will be in the next version of
the tree and then you can tolerate
having a really long time between trees
so the way this would work so Alice
would say you know please add my key Bob
is gonna ask for Alice's key before it
actually gets added so you know imagine
that the tree is only updated every day
or something like that and then the
server will respond well you know I have
this pending new key for Alice it's not
actually in the tree yet I promise I'm
gonna add it soon so here's the key you
can you know send a message to Alice now
so Bob gets the key and gets a sign
promise from the server saying that it's
going to be in the next version of the
tree and then the key is that Bob has to
actually verify this later so if the
server doesn't actually put
in the next version of the tree bob will
have proof that the server cheated but
of course bob has to actually wait
around and check that so I noticed like
a few people shaking their head and
saying this sounds you know maybe like a
little bit of a weird security model it
turned out working with Google they also
really didn't want to do this because
the engineering complexity of it was a
lot they have to track all of these
different promises and sort of make sure
they all get into the next version so on
paper this is like a good solution but
in practice is a little hard to
implement so another approach that kind
of fixes this problem is that you put a
version number in every time you bind
you know a user name to a key you put a
version number which says how many times
that key has changed and then as the
tree is updated like Alice's key got
changed here so now she's on to version
2 so that seems like a really small
change but you can see how it actually
fixes the problem now because if you've
been offline for a really long time and
your version number hasn't changed you
don't have to actually go and check all
the old versions because you can just
say my version number is the same as it
used to be and as long as these version
numbers can only go up that means that
you know your key couldn't have changed
in the meantime
but this introduces this kind of tough
problem that somebody has to be checking
this property that version numbers are
well-formed that they only go up so
somebody would have to be downloading
the tree at every epoch and checking
that the version numbers were all
maintained correctly and you know once
if you like that model the kind of
natural extension is instead of just
storing the versions you can actually
store the history of all previous
versions of key that this user has had
so slightly more powerful but Simkin
cept and same problem that somebody has
to go and actually check that this is
all correct so Google's key transparency
project is actually launching with this
model and their assumption is that
of some good citizen on the internet
will download the whole thing and check
that the whole data structure is
well-formed and as long as you trust
that somebody is going to go do all that
work then the system is secure and
remember that if somebody is doing the
auditing and finds that like at some
point a version number one in the wrong
direction they would have cryptographic
proof so they could publish it and say
you know look something went wrong here
the server cheated and sort of messed
with a version number I'm kind of in the
same way you know when you audit for non
equivocation if you if the server
actually cheats you get evidence and you
can whistle blow and prove that they're
untrustworthy
if the server you know was cheating with
the version numbers you would be able to
to to prove it another approach that I
actually implemented last year is kind
of a proof of concept because it was fun
you can do this whole thing in etherium
which is a really cool powerful
cryptocurrency that's fully programmable
it turns out you can actually write an
aetherium smart contract that does all
of the checking for you it checks the
structure of the tree and checks that
the version numbers go in the right
direction and then as long as the
etherium system is secure this sort of
guarantees that the tree will be
well-formed
so this is kind of a cool way rather
than trusting that some random third
party person will do all this auditing
for well-formed structure of the tree
you can have the etherium Network do it
for you but you'd have to pay them so
computation aetherium costs money turns
out it costs a fair amount of money so
you know it would cost on the order of
like pennies per day per user to pay the
network to do this auditing for you
which isn't yeah but penny I mean if you
have a billion users and it's a penny a
day for each one and yeah then that that
adds up pretty quickly
all right so I I wrote a large survey
paper with some colleagues that sort of
looked at all the different ways users
can verify keys
and we when we scored out the conic
system we said wow it really provides a
lot of great properties it's completely
transparent to the user it's sort of the
performance is good it scales all these
other things it sort of adds almost
every property that we want but there's
like a big hole here which is that it
doesn't actually prevent
man-in-the-middle attacks so you can
sort of get all the the usability and
performance properties that you want and
what we've thrown away is that attacks
are not actually prevented so what the
the system the property that actually
provides you is that if the if the
server is publishing a key for you
that's not right you'll know you'll get
this proof and you'll say look that that
your software will be able to warn you
and say that the server is telling
people your key is something that it's
not but you can't actually prove that to
anybody else you know you can say the
server is publishing the wrong key for
me and the server can say no this is the
right key if you want kind of the
natural thing that you know crypto
people will propose is we just need
another key and Bob will use that to
sign every time he changes his key and
then the server can't you know change
Bob's key without Bob signature yeah
exactly so it's circular you know the
the problem that we've started with is
that users are not good at managing keys
they lose them so we said we're gonna go
for this weaker security model and use a
transparency system then we had the
problem that we can't actually prove
this behavior and the solution that we
know of is sort of make users manage
another key and then we're sort of back
in square one
well yeah but the problem so the attack
would be like the server publishes a new
key for you and then they say oh yeah
like actually Henry called us last night
and he asked for a new key or he came
into the store and he showed us his
driver's license then you can say like
no I didn't write but they could provide
a receipt that makes it look like it's
you because remember that was the user
experience that we really want is that
users sort of lose everything and then
they sort of recover by some out-of-band
mechanism that's inherently not going to
be provable cryptographically yeah right
I'm just gonna say the bread when you
can you change if you sign it with your
sign it with your home key yeah right
yes that that like a continuity model
but you know users lose their old key
right like their old key is probably on
it on a phone and a lake yeah so we have
to be able to recover from that so I
think you know it's kind of an open
question how much security does this
really bias in the real world is this
property that you know you can users
will know if the server is cheating for
them is that kind of enough the claim is
that you know this is this provides you
with some reasonable hedge against mass
surveillance that if some intelligence
agency wants to sort of update
everybody's key to man-in-the-middle all
traffic that that's probably not going
to work because every user in the world
is gonna get a warning that their key is
wrong and you know that's gonna be
enough evidence in the real world not
cryptographic evidence but kind of you
know human level evidence that this
system is being backdoored but you know
if a few targeted attacks are made a few
users might be kind of complaining on
Twitter and saying you know I just got
this message that the server changed my
key and I didn't ask for it
that's probably not gonna be enough to
convince the world that the systems not
trustworthy anymore
there's always a few users complaining
on on Twitter about something you know
you probably will have some users
complaining that the server is
misbehaving even if it's not so you know
I would say is that
kind of a caveat of this approach is
that you know the it's probably a good
defense against the server attacking
everybody but a few sporadic attacks
it's not going to produce compelling
evidence of those users will still learn
but forward security they still don't
get the previous communications yeah
that's true
sure so one term that's come up before a
security fatigue and it's I understand
that if some actor decides to try to
mandate a middle a lot of people that a
lot of people are getting get alerts
from their clients telling them hey your
key has been changed what they say see
your key is has been changed is there
any protection to stop some actor from
simply saying okay I'm going to err
that's dedicated to simply flooding the
network with new keys for every random
identifier I can make with the intention
being that people will just get this
message hey oh until they just get so
tired they just go somewhere else right
thing that could denial of attention I
don't think so because you know you only
get warned of your key changed and some
random person can't change your key you
know assuming the server is honest some
third party can't change your key right
like they need to know your password or
your driver's license or whatever
process you're gonna authenticate to the
server with they can create a bunch of
other identities and change keys but the
software won't warn you about that right
that was like kind of our whole goal was
to get rid of warnings in that case
server when I use three servers and
drive countries and yeah we vote so you
can I mean that might provide you
something I mean it may be it gets a
little bit harder then because you know
if you're if you're doing some
out-of-band verification after
yeah
so the issue is like if you have to go
in person and show your I know but when
you've lost all your keys so when you
when you have to recover it becomes much
harder to reopen ticket to multiple
servers so you either sort of have one
one server that does reallocation in
which case they're kind of a you know
trusted choke point or it's a lot of
work on the user to to change their key
and all three servers okay let me just
show I had a lot of more stuff that I
could say about conics and other things
to show you one other thing that I has
been instructive for me so there's you
know another really big challenge is
communicating to users what security
properties different apps have so you
know I spend a lot of time a tff working
on this project to have a secure
messaging scorecard where we would show
different applications and try to
summarize their security properties in a
really simple way for users so we
workshop this for awhile and we ended up
coming up with seven criteria here that
we would evaluate for different apps and
then we had you know a very simple
scorecard with check boxes for different
apps and we published this on the web
and the goal was to give kind of a very
rough scorecard on how different tools
were doing you know so you can see the
different properties here and we we
tried to make them simpler by not using
crypto jargon so we didn't talk about
forward secrecy we said are your past
communications secure if your keys are
stolen and we didn't say and then
encryption we said encrypted so the
provider can't read it
so I turned out you know I was I can
admit now this project was a kind of a
failure on two fronts such as a little
sad the security community felt like
this was a gross oversimplification
and it gave people kind of too much
confidence in some apps there were some
apps that people thought were insecure
but yet hit these seven boxes and they
said this shouldn't be getting a perfect
score because it's not a perfect
application so you know the security
community felt like this was too much of
a simplification and you know we should
sort of ask more of users that you know
give them more information and when we
showed it to users so I just finished a
year-long project with some colleagues
in in the UK we did 60 hour-long
interviews with different users where
they talked about all of their secure
messaging habits and they sat down with
the score card and read it and tried to
understand it and the conclusion was
that I think of the 60 users basically
58 of them didn't understand it at all
and two of them understood about half of
it and not only did they not understand
it but they say their understanding was
exactly opposite of what we wanted for
parts of it so all of the users thought
the code being open proper design and
code audits they all thought that these
were negative properties so they thought
that the app would be less secure if the
code was open to outside review so I
guess it makes sense but I mean it was
it was a little disappointing to see
that that you know the general public
still definitely believes in security by
obscurity knew that open was a bad work
when he started used it anyway I didn't
know as a bad word maybe maybe what you
did because it's always been a bad word
because he you're not that you know I
mean I feel like on the web openness
people are always putting open in front
of stuff is it good
yeah uh-huh yeah yeah yeah so yeah I
mean I don't disagree that it was a bad
choice but to me it seemed like a good
choice at the time the whole bit of
outside the geek community open source
is seen as oh no no you want to be
secret inside Microsoft yeah but you see
you knew it when you knew it you knew
that that was your mother's right
reaction well your mother might be
different but maybe I overlooked it yeah
so yeah so this sort of bottom half here
this sort of openness which are sort of
we thought were good signs of project
health
people didn't like those gluten
Housekeeping Seal of Approval
yeah which could be completely closed
well because there's sort of no perfect
app so we didn't really know what we
would give the checkbox for and then
give an X to everything else so but the
even sadder thing so users didn't
understand they didn't know what
encryption meant at all actually when we
asked them most users when we described
encryption they basically described
encoding so they said encryption is the
process of taking the text and turning
it into ones and zeros so that it can be
sent across the wire so I'm like
completely serious over half the users
thought of encryption is basically you
know looking up the character code in
utf-8 yeah so users didn't understand it
and when we explained what we meant the
users completely rejected the notion
that end-to-end encryption was even
possible
so we basically described we said end
end encryption is a way that the only
people that can read the data are you
and the person that you're talking to
and Google or Apple aren't actually
allowed to read it people just stopped
and said I don't believe it and they
said there's no way that's possible I
know that they can read everything apps
like can't provide that property and you
know the appeal to experts saying sort
of
scientists have been working on this
problem and cryptography can provide
this people just refused in the
interviews ended and people went home so
it was actually really disturbing to me
kind of deeply as a as a crypto
researcher to realize that the general
public is kind of so far from
understanding what we're able to do
system you know they see what the ants
doing
yes you could argue that maybe the
people are slightly more you know
something to it there but what we asked
a bunch of follow-up questions and
that's not what they were thinking some
of your customers may believe that may
not believe that Apple has distributed
to their computer or program that does
what they say it does and that people
could read yes I mean that's the same
same point so we were worried about that
so we asked kind of follow-up questions
and they were they were one or two
people who sort of made that point with
Apple specifically they said Apple owns
the phone so you know they that they
control everything the phone does but
most users when we actually pressed that
wasn't actually what they were getting
at it was kind of amazing they just
fundamentally like didn't understand how
encryptions yeah
so we've I guess I'll just conclude and
I can take some more questions by saying
yeah there's still I think what's a
really big problem is you know a really
big open challenge is figuring out a way
to kind of open people's imaginations a
little bit and you know show that crypto
is possible that it can do good things
and that there are kind of technical
safeguards against surveillance you know
this this work definitely made me
realize that were much much further away
from that than I imagined that we were
while pointing out that cryptographers
are not singled out by the general
public as being people not believe most
scientists are singled out not to be
believed and but I thought
cryptographers had a you know I didn't
think that the public had any reason to
be skeptical about cryptographers there
hasn't been a big political campaign you
know like with climate science
just to say that cryptographers are are
charlatans right that's a certain event
that's even an issue here it's the
reasons behind the rejection of science
probably have very little to do with
reality yeah yeah I was gonna say they
didn't target people probably have done
a pretty good job of destroying
organizational people think of as
cryptographer string computers are all
insecure they don't know what they're
doing this is yeah that's definitely
true this whole of course presumes a
uncorrupted platform to roam yeah yeah I
mean it's at the beginning like if we
don't have secure software then you know
nothing's gonna work what's gonna happen
to your scorecard in the face of the
investigatory power is that well I mean
the scorecards not gonna what well the
scorecard is not gonna be banned yeah
can't get this checkmark in England
fitness checkmark in Latvia can't get
this checkmark in Hong Kong yeah Kenny
that's check mark in Boston we are we
are redoing this scorecard it's gonna
relaunch in the spring and we realized
that you know this was not working so
the new format is gonna just basically
have tiers and say like these are good
apps these are sort of it's gonna be
sort of like a good better and like
avoid it's a certification that the
materials used in the construction of
the device
don't burn right easy and maybe that's
something that you might do better with
a EFS
cryptos safe for something seal of
approval which basically summarizes the
seven points here in in a totally
obscure plot but the reputation of the
group producing it is carried forward
and yeah I guess it's not clear to me
who that party would be I mean for some
in the tech community they really trust
EF f s-- opinion so the scorecard did
get you know it was getting millions of
pages every month and you know in some
sense it was popular with a certain
group that's sort of globally the FF
brand name doesn't mean so much I mean
I'm not sure underwriters under
underwriter labs means much to the
general public either
yeah Consumer Reports I guess a bit but
even is that when you look at consumer
devices you designed them you
manufacture them and then they're locked
in and they're manufactured over some
period of time if you extended that to
software you have to redo the entire
process every time you updated the
software because you don't know what's
changed or a small change is there a big
effect one thing that might be
interesting is by which I mean there is
already training standards and licensing
standards for people like architects you
could move that same type of the
software that you want to trust just
like you're doing certification
requirements for buildings yeah I mean I
guess my response to that would be some
of the most widely used crypto in the
world that I think cryptographers would
really vouch for whether it's signal or
something like curve two five five one
nine is written by people who probably
wouldn't have quality
for a certification and would have
actively refused to sit down and get one
I'm serious like the crypto is often
developed by people without formal
credentials
I mean signal in particular like signal
is usually the app that people have the
most confidence in and then the main
developer of signal is a self-taught
cryptographer so I guess I'm not okay
and if you're looking at like an
architect an architect didn't create the
seal is going he's just taking the
pieces and putting them together in some
hopefully safe way so I'm not ever going
to design curve to 5 5 1 9 but I'm
hopefully going to use it in a safe way
that doesn't just completely break
everything there was at one point I
think some thought about that but I
think there was like they'd sort of
wanted to have copyright and sort of
limit who can look at the scorecard so
you know PFF wanted to do some public
thing that we could put on the web and
everybody could mean consumer reports is
like a company and they sell to
subscribers so it's like a business
model clash clash terrors use it and you
need to in order to protect you we have
to know what you're saying really had
much penetration in the public psyche
where they think that what you're
aspiring to isn't even a good thing no I
mean actually I was like that didn't
come up that much in our interviews
there wasn't much of like a negative
perception of encryption people just
they didn't know what it was or what I
could do but but yeah I guess I didn't
really see you mean very well respected
being technically confident at the NSA
used to be you know so special no it's
they knew what they were doing that's I
think actually I mean it's interesting I
mean I went to grad school in the UK so
you know I spend a lot of time there the
the UK public has a much more positive
relationship with its intelligence
agencies and I think the u.s. does they
have kind of a yeah well they also have
kind of a revered place in British
society dating back to Bletchley Park
and the war yeah so yeah I mean I think
they do have a pretty good reputation
for competence in the UK which you know
might explain why the UK has past been
able to pass much more aggressive you
know surveillance laws for being
extremely competent but maybe suspect in
their intentions to accept that they
might be planning to sneak back doors
into something I'm not sure even I would
trust the NSA wasn't endorsement by them
might be a proof of their being a
weakness of some sort right we have
specialized populations namely reporters
and lawyers what's their uptake and
what's their approach they all use Cemal
now yeah a lot too so you know AFF works
with those groups a lot we published
like a whole series of Doc's called the
surveillance self-defense guide that
walks through exactly how to install you
know not just secure messaging tools but
things like tor or the tails operating
system on different platforms so yeah I
mean that there's a lot of outreach to
those communities and yes signal is
really popular among journalists now I
mean and it's even I mean actually the
anecdote is that the Hillary Clinton
campaign switched from email to signal
internally in about September well they
were getting killed by email leaks
obviously yes that's right but so
they're yeah
like signal has
it's got some pretty dedicated users
among a couple of different activist
communities and and so signal they might
I mean they've you know they've they've
already you know sent one legal request
to signal so yeah it's possible but I
don't know the Trump administration that
a reporter asked the e FF you know a
reporter asked the FFF what we would
expect from the Trump administration
with regards to surveillance and we
actually have no idea so I mean I
wouldn't say people are hopeful but
there isn't like a long track record of
of statements on surveillance or tech
policy in general from Trump so would be
interesting times probably is there any
serious concern about hardware being
compromised because I was recently at a
talk where someone was proposing to have
a system where you have completely
verify Hardware finding completely nerf
ID software is that anything that people
need to seriously think about yeah I
mean I think there's there's definitely
like concern about dimple yeah I mean
yeah like is your iPhone compromised
yeah I think there are I mean depends on
your definition of compromised but yeah
like I think it's not crazy to think
that certain things you know may be
there so that definitely that I don't
know the way I view it though to answer
your question is you know we should get
the software right and then if the if
the software is alright in the attack
that people are forced into is that they
have to actually compromise the hardware
then we sort of won something right if
you don't even have to go after the
hardware because people are all running
and secure software are not encrypting
and compromised at this point yeah and
it was not highly likely
it's whatever else a realistic sense of
hope it used to be the case that the
base band had DMA access on most phones
and so well it's actually changing a lot
from recent punks it's just a peripheral
that's essentially connected via USB
I mean optimized in the sense that the
base band could do anything a lot to
write foreign governments starting to
audit these things against other
intelligence agencies like I'm sorry on
foreign governments like China starting
to audit iPhones for example against
foreign intelligence agencies spying on
American citizens
oh so you're asking like is Chinese
intelligence auditing iPhones you know
we'd like you the foreign company to
show us that some foreign intelligence
agency isn't doing mass surveillance of
our citizens not that I know of
yeah I don't know I haven't seen any
evidence that the Chinese government is
like specifically auditing phones are
asking to see I mean there has been a
lot of concern there's been a lot of
talk about people especially in Europe
wanting to move data centers out of the
US and not rely on u.s. services
interesting yeah I guess I don't know
the Chinese situation so well so I
probably can't say very much
cool alright thanks everybody
you